[Music]
let's
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go lil nazax and jack harlow have their
marching orders at the mtv video music
awards tonight performance is gonna be
really sexy it's gonna be a vma moment
the rapper kicked off the performance
with his hit single industry baby
[Music]
and to top it off little nausea received
an epic introduction from billy porter
so brooklyn
get ready for the slayage we've all been
living for
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
then welcomed his industry baby collab
partner to the barclays center main
stage i don't clear a rumor hey where's
your sense of humor i'm the making jokes
cause they are all like baby boomers
turn my haters to consumers i make
deaths feel like they juniors say your
time is coming
[Music]
the 21 year old music star closed out
his performance by going to the big
house and tonight we learned that pink
is the new orange at montero state
prison
[Music]
was one of the vmas top contenders of
the evening with five nominations
including a video of the year nom for
call me by your name e.t caught up with
lil nasaks and jack harlow before their
performance you are serving up some
fashion tonight huh
yeah stop it
go away tell me more tell me more now
wait a second i was expecting a bump
tonight but what can we expect from your
performance tonight performance is going
to be really sexy
shocking i want to say yeah it's
shocking i won't say shocking i hate
cause i'm getting tired of hearing that
word it will just be a bma moment
because the vmas are known for moments
it's going to be a vma moment okay
and what about your nominations how are
you feeling about that i'm really happy
to like win all these nominations and um
you know i'm going on stage with jack
harlow
what is that jack do not say anything
sush
jack what has it been like collaborating
step on don't step on the the okay you
can step on it jackie jack harlow what
has it been like collaborating with this
genius over here
you don't want me to say it do you want
to let's go let's get your next one
thank you thank you this dude means so
much to me
[Music]
you